[Music]
puh-puh-puh buh-buh-buh
hey kids Friday night nine o'clock in
Los Angeles completely quarantined Los
Angeles and so I'm just here in the
house in my office in the fat cave where
we record all the podcasts and stuff and
as as I said it's nine o'clock at night
well at 10:00 after 9:00 in Los Angeles
and I don't eat past 8 o'clock that's my
thing like that's not my thing I think
it's a lot of people's thing but I I
don't do that try to control my weight I
was on tour for a while with Jane saw
Bob reboot Roadshow tour thank the
heavens it ended right before all this
quarantine stuff happened and whatnot
but in any event why not bring that up
[ __ ] was I just bragging had a good
point oh you know what [ __ ] escape me
probably because I'm smoking I don't
know if we're allowed to smoke on
Instagram but this Bob poisons diet mad
Dugan's got to be some Lubriderm modules
look at that there's a face you could
trust on your jar of weed
um ooh look at this man this is [ __ ]
best news that I got well second best
news I got all day ready yeah son
rosario dawson could play ahsoka in
season 2 of the mandalorian [ __ ]
loved that show that shows genius and
her playing a live action so good
is everything ok so I'm sitting here I'm
trying not to eat man try not to eat
past 8 o'clock it's 9 o'clock and I'm
hungry not I'm not hungry I'm bored
that's the thing I you know trapped in
quarantine I'm sure a lot of you have
noticed that like you know sometimes
it's easy to just default to eating as
entertainment and that's how I lived
most of my life up until and after the
heart attack and what
I was that guy who was just like well
you know you know whenever I eat is when
I eat and [ __ ] like that $90 hours and
stuff so post heart attack I was like
I'm not even past 8 o'clock and so far
it's worked out
I also intermittently fast like
yesterday not two days ago I needed it
all but then you know the next day I had
a really nice beef barley soup from
veggie grill so I don't want to eat is
what I'm getting at right now try not to
eat man it's like [ __ ] 9 o'clock on a
Friday night there's a part of me that's
like reward yourself man because the
[ __ ] other greatest thing real the
best thing happened to me all day was I
saw image of myself from The Simpsons
I'm gonna be on The Simpsons as myself I
do a voice and it was amazing and I'm on
the episode that airs on Sunday so you
know is everything's coming up millhouse
even though I'm here in quarantine
but it's so there's a part of me that
wants to reward myself right like it's
Friday night just got paid on the
Simpsons and Rosario is a souca like
just celebrating and stuff so naturally
I wanted to fall to food and eat so I
don't want to eat so instead I'm hanging
out here chatting at you all and stuff
this is an effort not to eat right now
so I'm sitting in the office I just got
off the tour as previously mentioned and
so not just but like a month ago and so
I'm unpacking and stuff that I've
accumulated along the way and I thought
I would share it with you show you some
stuff I got this this is a cool board
man cool ass will I do it would you want
some people of course like myself would
use that perhaps rule of joy that was
given to me by one of our sound editors
when Jane saw Bob reboot just got home
just found it look at this are you stuck
at home
we all looking for something to do I
just done heard these bad boys look at
this
Jay and Silent Bob's smell my finger
game that's a real [ __ ] thing man
look at that there's us on the back up
to no good and stuff there's that one or
the good folks the place to him also
have this Jay and Silent Bob's big fat
card on game so what if game like you
had this power and this power you know
like we sit around talk to your friends
about superheroes and stuff like that I
found a box of that man I forgot like
you know we I give those out at the next
Batman Beyond if we ever have fat man
beyond again but if not if you want to
play these they're on Amazon right now
target well you know their websites cuz
nobody on their person don't leave your
house to go get these but you know if
you're bored you're like I don't have
enough games that game looks interesting
to me
smell my finger game maybe not the game
to be playing you know outside the house
during the pandemic and stuff but anyway
found that look what else I go no well
this I didn't find this but I got to
appreciate this when I came home so you
know I'm working on the Masters in the
universe and one of our writers Tim who
wrote some amazing [ __ ] episodes
including episode 9 and 7 Tim gave me
this look at this amazing print Skeletor
sexy Skeletor come on man
look at that not genius
Tim such a good guy under that right
there that's a fake covered to a Dogma
laserdisc that doesn't exist and under a
fan sent that to me when I was on the
book and under that look at this it's a
fake Ranger danger laser disc
those are real data discs under there or
Howard the Duck notes and packages and
artwork and and scripts for the from the
ill-fated and Howard the Duck projects
and stuff now we'll gather dust in my
office I bet you unless we have a fire
or you know [ __ ] the pandemic takes
us or whatever if this if I still live
in this house within 10 years that we'll
still be sitting exactly where it is
right now speaking of cool [ __ ] I got on
the road look at this I got a little
award man it's from a violet verse she
says the award of excellence for the
best reboot remake in sequel how awesome
is that
she's a door of a little kid if you ever
saw the episode of the comic book men
where we did like the secret stash
you know anniversary and stuff we got in
the Guinness Book of World Records
little violet was in that episode
look at this nice piece of artwork a guy
on the road would it's made of [ __ ]
wood man it's like really [ __ ] sweet
there is a thing Jason gave me to
celebrate tusk to my hetero life mate
you are the king and I love you more
than words can express
thank you for being you and letting me
experiment experience an awesome mind at
work you know he's a poor judge of
character
thank God look at this bill see some
cabbage artwork that's my character
onomatopoeia
there he is again Matt Wagner cover to
Green Arrow
all right what did I want to show you
all right check this [ __ ] out man
these are well these are the things that
I got from artists on the road so this
is head straight the band I guess is
their name head straight and it's Alex
Clark game of this and it's it says the
babe
it's called buried the album fade
alchemy a blu-ray the people who suspend
by Lucas Larsson Lucas
gave me this and said very nice things
about how I inspired him as a filmmaker
and he made this movie about people that
hang themselves like not hang themselves
hang themselves the way we all think of
it like hang suspend themselves amazing
and here's to Kevin Smith from John face
mere minutes quit mere a squid man face
mirror I saw him on tour so many times
she's such a sweetheart John okay but
look at this sweet gift man this is the
Jane sambar reboot extras autographed
trading card set one of one there's only
one of these in the whole world man
Laura dobberstein put this together I
mean let me put a camera on it it says
Kevin within these pages are a small
number of people who were honored to
help make your vision for reboot a
reality thank you for letting us play in
the sandbox the extras and look what
they did extra thanks to all these fat
cats pity look what they did all their
characters have trading cards all these
people were extras in reboot it was
Darrell and they wrote on the back of
the cards man like pages and pages
there's the walrus guy rambin pages upon
pages there's the voodoo zombie plump
man J just broke his his bomb when we
were at New Orleans it's such a
beautiful thing man
like this I love gifts like this these
this mod squad kids man right there
stoner all right this this was about
like the most touching thing I could
have possibly received there's nice
Lyceus lighters from Laura from gen
Kaminsky look at those are so nice so
Laura made the book thank you so much
like I've been sitting here going
through it and rolling tears Jen made
those lighters with drawsome I think
you'd give them the stash this is the
last thing I want to share with you
because we could do this for hours I'm a
hoarder they could do one of those
[ __ ] shows here man and people will
be like
you like the Silent Bob there was a TV
show forget what it was I never seen it
but somebody I've read about it on
Twitter where they made some joke
plugins years ago where they were like
not that many years ago like maybe five
or six or something but they were like
this is grosser than Kevin Smith's
refrigerator door or something like that
and I remember being like that doesn't
make sense but whatever
I guess the implication was like he's
heavy so he opens his door a lot and
[ __ ] and he's gross I don't think that
shows on the air anymore point being if
the show had been like ill Kevin Spence
gross because he hoard [ __ ] I you know I
would have been like they got me dead to
rights cuz look at this [ __ ] alright
this is just [ __ ] clutter man this is
just well she's essential right they
look that way look at this this a box
filled with [ __ ] video tapes video
tapes what am i giving around of that
look at that loose [ __ ] piled up in the
corner look at all this stuff I mean I
look I think that that shit's the museum
and I think it's honestly placed like
these top shelves you see are art
directed within an inch of their lives
they're curated as [ __ ] there's a big
naked portrait of my wife and there's me
and the wife and there's an awesome
Steve rude painting of Jay and Silent
Bob with Bluntman and chronic on top of
her heads
there's awesome Bad News Bears painting
by Man Wonder Broz Mike who years ago
gave me this to give to Ralph and
Ralph's coming over some tomorrow
morning tomorrow afternoon so we're
going to I'm gonna finally give it to
him
but look at all this clutter look at
this [ __ ] that chair came from Greg
Grunberg
look at all it look at just clutter man
like this is one of those like look at
this those are notes from my high school
girlfriend
Kim Loughran sent me those notes like in
the 80s and I still have them like
that's that's the kind of [ __ ]
hoarding [ __ ] that I am and stuff I
always tell myself if I have enough time
one day I'm gonna clean all this [ __ ] I
feel like I've got time kids I'm here
man before we get out I'll show you my
family little thing here little family
collection yeah this guy smoked window
here watch this [ __ ] bah bah well that
didn't even work make sure see my room
or um but you know - smoked window
anyway it's me and my dad there's Scott
holding Harley when she was born there's
my dad holding Harley when she was born
he was cute business cards from circa
clerks my parents with my kid this is
when my brother got married
back in 1994 there's my dad at pictures
at the end of Jersey girl that's also my
dad when he was a baby
um ooh let me let me share one one more
thing with you excited found this
sometimes the clutter is not even
[ __ ] mine it's other people's but I
found this and this is kind of oddly
fascinating this is the deed to my
parents house from 21 Jackson Street the
house I grew up in man the choices that
they made to buy this house shaped the
individual that I became clerks now that
[ __ ] happens if my parents don't buy
this house at 21 Jackson Street in
Highlands New Jersey they've sold that
they don't live there when my dad's dead
my mom don't live there and every once
in a while I wimzie about buying my
childhood home and stuff but oh my god
it's expensive now real estate so
expensive and then sandy took the house
out the house that I grew up in it left
the wolf for walls and then a new owner
built up like put it up 16 feet in the
air and stuff so kinda looks like my old
house but not my house and you know here
there's a story about that like look I
mean look at this something I got on the
road from a fan this beautiful little
piece of artwork of course was
nice this genius book by David Gotti
which I think you could get online man
is a Kevin Smith scrapbook I love it but
look at this see this camera this came
from two guys the veterans of j-dog
Savannah thanks for all laughs in a big
bad way
snoo guns so see that that's an Arri sr
to kids our ESR to an error flex SR to
that's the camera well Ann arias r2 is
the kind of camera that we shot clerks
on and those cats remembered that and so
they were like I saw them at a show in
Georgia I guess it says Savannah maybe
so I think it was in Georgia but they
said here man this for you and I was
like holy [ __ ] is an area sore - where'd
you get this
and they said we clean out places and
and we were cleaning out a film school
we got hired to clean out of film school
and I saw this camera I was like I guess
r2 is now a Kevin Smith said they shot
Clark's not and he gave me that camera
how [ __ ] sweet is that so suddenly
after getting that camera I became like
obsessed I was like wait a second
shouldn't I own the air they real Arius
r2 that we shot clerks to Ana's a Arya
there's some people most people say all
right but you know Jersey so I said I
must it became for like five minutes
it became my rosebud I had a mission
where I was like I'm gonna track down
the arias are two that we've rented from
Spira corp back in 1993 and worry I'm
gonna then I'll own it and I'll be
complete and then I said to myself you
know this rational self kicked in and I
said you know what like look if you ever
happened across the camera that made
clerks one day of course look and I
wouldn't turn it away but you know the
camera the camera didn't make clerks
camera didn't have the magic cameras
just a tool me and my friends made
clerks and there's still most of them in
my life and alive so you know be nice to
have that camera but cameras not
important anyway that metaphor or that
little thing comes back to my parents
deed because every once in a while I'm
like oh I want to own my child
um how weird wonderful would that be in
full circle and stuff but you know
that's that house was just a house and
it's not even the house I grew up in
anymore it's just a house that's on the
property I used to grow up on that kind
of resembles the shape of what I grew up
in but the magic wasn't the house magic
was my parents my brother and my sister
and Highland's New Jersey circa 1972
when did I finally leave 93 when we made
clerks and it's still magical of course
but that era when I lived there
that was my hometown cue Bruce
Springsteen in any event I love that
house I'm 21 Jack's is true this is the
bill of sale from W Isidore Ackerman
that's who had our house before my
parents bought it to Donald Smith and
Grace Smith dated 1966 let's see how
much that [ __ ] cost let's see how much
joy costs all right and we'll spin
around so you can read it with me all
right his door Ackerman March 25th 1966
this Ackerman selling to Donald Smith
and grace Virginia Smith comma his wife
you know different days here you go kids
my house my childhood home in 1966
12,500 bucks man with five dollars and
74 cents thrown on for taxes son of a
[ __ ] so bringing the grand total to 12
505 my parents put down a thousand bucks
and then spent the next 20 years paying
off eleven thousand dollars man isn't
that nuts there's all your info and
she'll like that nothing that will ever
mean anything to anything anybody
anymore
that
in this document lies the origin of
clerks look I can trace everything back
to Clark's because you know [ __ ] and
an entertainer that means I'm a
narcissist it means everything's about
me and it all comes back to me but that
document in that document the remember
of [ __ ] JFK when Donald Sutherland
was like in that document live the
Vietnam War in that document lies clerks
man nice we don't get to clerks without
that and stuff that little home that
used to be in mommoth poor mama the the
base amount was base called Fort
Monmouth it was a small like bungalow
that had been on the property there and
they moved it to Highlands long before
we got there and turned it into a home
of some sort and [ __ ] like that that
shaped who I became man and shaped the
[ __ ] I did and the choices I made and
the things that I experienced and the
things I had and the things that did not
have and stuff and without that you
don't get anywhere so you know thank God
mom and dad mustered up that thousand
bucks and bought that house house my
childhood at home and I'll tell you what
right now man would it cost twelve five
I'll give you 12 five [ __ ]
I'll give you twelve million dollar I
don't have that I'll give you I'll give
you I'll give you all the money I got if
you can get me back to the real 21
Jackson Street not the one that they
reconstructed for this quarantine that
would be [ __ ] awesome it'd be amazing
to be a twenty-one Jackson Street cooped
up for months you would ask me that
years ago ah I got a guy out here
actually I was never one of those kids
that wanted to get home I stayed there
as long as I possibly could Nash it was
free but today all the holy [ __ ] I'll
give you all the money I got you'd give
him back there to that moment in time
man hmm
so beautiful so perfect man I anyway
that's it you know what not hungry
there you go I wasn't hungry at all
begin with but the boredom of wanting to
eat has also passed so now I could no no
kick back have an iced tea and [ __ ] like
that and then if I could make you know
and I will make it through the night and
[ __ ]
I won't eat til tomorrow at noon and
I'll feel fantastic I lost four pounds
last week man you know put on [ __ ]
ten or more when I was on tour [ __ ] so
I'm trying to chisel that [ __ ] back off
and whatnot McGeorge got a little snug
and I was used to them not being that
snug so I've been hiking Ronnie and
stuff socially distancing from everybody
but I'll be happy tomorrow man that I
did this instead of eating unless I said
something that gets me cancelled on the
internet then I'll be like why didn't I
[ __ ] eat
I'm so stupid now I'm racing through
everything I said is there anything
offensive did I offend bankers I'm
talking about my parents putting down
thousand dollars did I offend the tax
people by bitching at the five-dollar
tax thing that was a joke people um
there it is kids thanks for hanging out
man
you were very helpful I always like to
do I hate Bern I like wearing beanies or
tooks if you will Canada but I I don't
like when I hide your ears so I try to
stick him out and that's that's fashion
nice gosh that's me being [ __ ] like
who I go look good for who must be
honest
[ __ ] 49 would be 50 in like a red hot
minute man in August which hopefully
hopefully we'll be out of quarantine but
if we're not holy [ __ ] you're gonna see
a lot more of this [ __ ] office oh I'm
gonna show you everything I'm gonna
start diving into [ __ ] and open it up in
what is this look at you like holy [ __ ]
there it is
enjoy your Fridays folks thanks for
hanging out making me feel less peckish
all right I'm going
[Music]
you